que se passe-t-il avec ces jeunes
lorsqu'ils sont relâchés que doit-on
faire j'en parle avec david morin et lee
politologue à l'université de sherbrooke
membre de l'observatoire sur la
radicalisation et l'extrémisme violent
monsieur morin bonsoir bonsoir c'est pas
la première fois qu'on identifie des
jeunes comme ça qu'ils sont prêts à
partir à les joindre les rangs de l'état
islamique est ce qu'on en a plus c'est
ce qu'on assiste à un engouement d'après
vous écoutez je pense que sans parler
d'engouement nécessairement on est
effectivement depuis quelques mois dans
un phénomène un petit peu d'accélération
alors vous savez que c'est toujours
cycliques cette question du terrorisme
un peu et là j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
effectivement une forme de dates et le
fait d'en parler et c'est ça va
probablement créer un effet
d'entraînement
je voyais un petit peu plus tôt que
certains d'entre vous parler de filière
je crois que effectivement là sans céder
à la panique il faut quand même bien
dire que oui il ya eu un essor de ce
phénomène là au cours des derniers mois
mais on en a déjà parlé ensemble qu'est
ce qui peut pousser ces jeunes qui sont
qui ont grandi ici qui sont éduqués à
vouloir joindre les rangs d'un mouvement
qu'on s'est extrêmement barbare oui mais
vous avez en fait beaucoup de caussens
c'est multifactoriel on a du mal à
déterminer des tendances lourdes parmi
tous les profils on a beaucoup de cas
qui sont finalement très différents les
uns des autres mais je vous dirais que
vous avez la rencontre entre des
parcours individuels parfois dans un
groupe et puis au contact dans un
contexte national ou international donc
vous avez des facteurs qui sont
l'adolescence d'abord évidemment mais
aussi peut-être parfois l'ostracisme
parfois une privation relative parfois
la discrimination parfois le sens de la
justice
le goût de l'aventuré pour notamment les
femmes par exemple on parle beaucoup
aussi du devoir humanitaire le fait de
venir on a des relations oui tout à fait
donc vous avez ici des discours qui sont
mis en place pour séduire finalement une
population assez jeune qui est réceptive
dans une forme de quête de sens et quête
identitaire mais après évidemment la
difficulté c'est de faire la part des
choses et puis de se souvenir que
finalement la plupart de ces jeunes qui
sont réceptifs à ce message ne vont pas
nécessairement passer à l'acte violent
soit à l'étranger soit sur notre
territoire donc mais une question c'est
de trouver ce point de basque mais ça
prend quand même de l'argent on parlait
d'un adolescent aujourd'hui alors que ça
prend des liens ça prend ça prend des
gens pour les aider à organiser un
voyage comme ça non oui absolument
écouter je me plais à dire ça depuis
depuis aujourd'hui c'est que
effectivement on a souvent parlé de la
puissance des réseaux sociaux etc de
l'internet beaucoup d'études montrent
aussi que l'internet seule ne suffit pas
et que souvent il ya un élément humain
qui sont des individus donc sous un
réseau d'individus soit même dans un
groupe d'amis l'un qui serait plus
influentes les autres mets donc un
facteur une relation humaine qui elle
peut être un déclencheur finalement de
ce type d'action et comme vous le disiez
effectivement ça prend de l'argent ça
prend des réseaux pour une fois qu'on à
l'étranger être pris en charge et c'est
donc je pense que l'une des priorités à
l'heure actuelle pour la police est
probablement d'essayer effectivement de
neutraliser les agents de radicalisation
parce que il semble de plus en plus
clair qu'il y en a un où quelques-uns à
l'heure actuelle à montréal - une toute
dernière question qu'est-ce qu'on fait
donc avec ces jeunes une fois ils ont
été relâchés cela alors qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec eux quel sort de prévention
peut faire oui bah écoutez je pense
qu'il faut rapidement restaurer le
dialogue avec eux il faut essayer de les
ramener finalement
vers vers la société qui est la leur il
faut essayer de contrecarrer le discours
propagandistes essayer de faire la
démonstration auprès d'eux que
finalement il est fondamental de ne pas
céder aux sirènes de cette cet
aventurisme c'est important si de
rétablir le lien probablement entre ces
jeunes et leurs familles qui elles aussi
se retrouve un petit peu démunis face à
cette situation l'a souvent pas au
courant du tout monsieur murray remercie
beaucoup ça m'a fait plaisir au revoir